any questions come in observation
notice I don't know if it's because
I'm not being as mindful as the lower
half of my body and I find that I'm not
doing
Oishi stuff I'm actually checking myself
out with each step and just yeah we saw
a lot of that so sent the same movement
that lends itself towards stability
grounding also lends itself towards
projection right sending energy away
from me
but it also is the same organization
that lends itself towards mobility so
for example let's take an obvious one
when you push your knee over your foot
okay and you require a great need to go
backwards or to change the angle off to
the flight you're going to have to bring
that knee back first over your ankle
before you can adopt a new vector so now
you just added time when you're falling
because you don't have the ground path
because you don't have the right ankle
angle like when we send your torso is
not over your hips and you're starting
to fall you if you're not having to step
in the very direction you were falling
you're going to have to regain your
balance you're going to have to put your
torso back over your hips right put the
rider back on the horse before you can
start to move in the other direction so
that's a whole extra step let's take the
opposite side you have locked your knees
out many of you when you come up you
seek height when when the movement is
happening that Joad on the upper level
your mind is pulled by it and as your
mind is pulled by it your body follows
so I'm working at Joad on my mind rut
rut raises and then my body raises how
by I lock my knees out so locked knees
is not the ground path
I needed a knee bed now if I have to
move what do I have to do I have to
first bend my knees and then I'll be
able to move so same thing you're not
rounding and you've added an extra move
on to whatever you need to do and that
requires more time you're slower so
there's not this contradiction or
antithetical relationship between
stability and mobility it's not a trade
off the overextended stance or the super
wide stance that somebody thinks is a
stability is not in the same way the
narrower stance or the moving stance
that someone thinks is only mobile it's
not it's very stable so go back to your
basics then where is my ankle angle
supposed to be what is the orientation
of my me where is my weight in
relationship to which foot I need to
move or not move just go to those basics
what is my hip to hip relationship what
is my shoulder to shoulder relationship
what is my shoulders to hip relationship
check for those and is my Center going
then go to the inner level what is my
mind in my panic am i breathing and my
shoulders up and my throat is tight have
I gone blind has my awareness gone in
and down it's no longer up and out just
run through the checklist every single
thing we're doing is just that over and
over and over at body organization every
technique
so I really
so here's the subtext of your question I
will address everybody learns at
different rates the structure though it
is always the same
I need exposure and to do that I need
proximity and presence then how much
exposure you need that's up to you that
has nothing to do with your teacher or
anyone else
so some somebody might get away with one
rep exposure got it someone else might
meet 10,000 reps of exposure so what if
you're going to sit there and go how do
I get it to one how do I make it 5,000
how do I at least cut it or now who
cares approach it the other way do I
have it
no more exposure what I tend to find is
that everybody's looking for shortcuts
when you look at a person who got it
down to one rep exposure you're not
going to see a person looking for
shortcuts you're not going to see a
person looking for life hacks magic
pills you're gonna see a person who kept
gaining exposure
ensuring proximity ensuring presence for
how long until they got it so the
question isn't really what do I do it's
what should I stop doing what is all the
other crap
that is stopping me from getting the
exposure that my body mind requires
anybody who's excelled at anything
because we're not that person we just
see the end product wow I can't believe
they can play the piano right now oh how
did they get so fluent in Japanese but
if you go and you follow them through
time you're gonna see them saying no to
a hell of a lot more things than they
said yes to they only say yes to one
thing right that exposure pattern but
they're saying no to everything else no
friend no girlfriend no we're not taking
that class no I'm not gonna do tap looks
cool but not gonna do it I need more
exposure
there's a writing that is quite funny
but very on the point his he's an author
writes on food Oh trained in Bluto Dave
lorry and he wrote an article and I
believe it's titled get a new wife so in
the article he's repeating if I remember
correctly either he's he's hearing the
story witnessing it or he's the one
that's doing it I can't remember I
apologize but this student is coming in
and like hey I can't find I can't find
the time train my wife wants me out
online now and the instructors answer
was get anyway and you might go wow
that's cold
that is it less truthful it's not it
goes back to hey you're not getting it
there's only one reason you need more
exposure you need more proximity you
need more presence that little cycle
that pattern that tripartite there's no
there's nothing magic magical to it
but how many things are we seeing yes -
and then we're wondering why that
formula is not working for us
sometimes I see I I can I can sense as a
senpai I'll speak to you now this is
very odd culture when you guys take days
off just to take days off to me the
formula that I found to work and is very
consistent across the board for mastery
especially for physical things that
require a recovery duration is four to
six hours a day you could go in the
sports world and you're gonna see the
same thing why is it not more because
you'll thrash your body but when they
say that they always in their heads like
if it could be we will make it so and
you know what let's go ahead and make it
so for now just so you'll have these
intensive camps yep we're gonna do it
seven to eight how long a week go for it
a week right monitor everything so when
I was at the Olympic training camp you
woke up breakfast and you go train and
lunch and then you go tray and dinner
and then you train and you go to bed
oh it's easily 78 hours and you ate
according to that right you don't know
I'm so starving
because you're gonna throw up cuz we got
it you're gonna be exhausted and you got
right five more hours to go before you
go to sleep before you wake up and do it
for six to two weeks more depending on
the intensive training because everyone
knows hey don't overcomplicate it
exposure proximity proximity is
proximity to the source the teacher the
teaching the art with whatever the ideal
and make sure you're not just going
through the motions presence
but as a senpai just to give you some
perspective for you to understand how
much no you really need to say your your
schedules are sometimes very interesting
to me because I know you're not a cop so
you know you don't have that day you
don't have that day of three to four
adrenaline dumps right shift work on top
of that huge responsibility it's very
draining Lea's coming on as an explorer
she's just following me around she told
me the other day I and I I did the same
I came home I just laid down and that
was it
she didn't know I did that she comes
home it was just one of those days and
she was like all sleep
but you're giving off the air of hey I
trained for days and I'm going to
balance my life out do you understand so
I'm going to balance my life and so I'm
going to now I'm going to spend time
with my girlfriend or I'm going to spend
time with my boyfriend or I'm going to
go do this but that's not an accurate
patient because you two out you're only
given two hours four days a week
what are you balancing this is where my
mind is coming from you're you're you're
not you're not at the middle way you
know the Buddhist path you're not at the
middle way you're still in the palace
with Siddhartha at the orgy do you get
it so when I hear your question I don't
get it on one rep I really hear you
saying how do i how do I get it
on one way how do i improve how do I not
require so many reps to get it use the
formula plug in the variables of the the
amounts that you require how do I know
those amounts if you're not getting it
keep adding keep adding that is what
everyone does so we have done things to
help you what are some of the things
we've done to help you gain exposure
when maybe you can't get out of the
palace yep everything is being put on
videos for you to look at over and over
and over again we have writings on it
over-over addressing it we also organize
the weeks training
the training we don't jump all over the
place right this is what we're working
on so you get repeated reps multiple
perspectives on it multiple
opportunities but even then if you're
not going to bother to watch a YouTube
video because you said yes to something
else then might as well be no YouTube
video if you're not going to show up
regularly and often through the week the
fact that we organize our teachings
weekly is a waste do you understand it
might as well be a haphazard thing if
you miss weeks at a time you will not
have the experience that we've been
building towards this your experience
will be this is a new thing I know
nothing about
if you're not reading the secret group
writings does there are people in the
dojo that just don't even read the
Facebook group well while it's there
they don't read it they don't belong to
it even there's people that don't belong
to it they go hey I don't I'm not gonna
do social media so I'm not gonna it's
odd to me as a senpai what you're not
going to take advantage of all this
material it's not worth it to you you
can't figure out how to address whatever
evil you think exists in social media
for the sake of all this material
so that exposure tripartite you you need
to understand it from the negative side
you need to figure out what am I saying
yes to that I should be saying no to I
have just one last example so you see
and one last tool you can use when I was
learning this I wouldn't plan my whole
day get a little calendar with the hours
and the whole day was planned okay you
just write it in you include sleep and
you include your meals you include
everything that requires you to be able
to perform at that high level so you
don't cut out sleep that's doable
you said I should say no so I'm gonna
say no to sleep and then I can keep
myself in the Chess Club and play the
clarinet full-time in a jazz band and I
could do Aikido
no you will not be able to do anything
well if you block off and get rid of
sleep so you can just start from there
I need eight to nine hours all right
that leaves me the rest and you'll find
whole decal I've got time everywhere
there's a lot of time by you're not
using that time between classes why did
I just walk and talk and chat and screw
around
why didn't I sneak in some pull-ups here
why don't I sneak in some push-ups there
why don't i watch a video here or there
because I'm saying yes to other things
so if it helps try the schedule but
mastery is always going to be about how
much more did you say no too
to check out that video there's a video
on this technique there's a video on a
you Miyoshi and there'll be a video on
the center
so a UV Yoshi is lower yon we haven't
done 10 cut yet it'll be lower yen right
and the cook you Doku is upper center
okay when I'll put those tags on there
this is this is my way that the body can
be understood
[Music]